what what kind of key do you what kind
of chord do you guys want me to start in
to kick off the New Year D Minor
starting D Minor oh you want a D Minor
the saddest of all the chords yes
because
we are witnessing the end of humanity
it's all happening
or is it
or is it hey everybody welcome back to
the corner digital podcast it's been a
while
um
but we're glad to be back so hello
welcome and uh thanks for being here uh
we had to come back we had something
with this groundbreaking Earth
shattering
cataclysmic
cataclysmic I like that word yes we are
we were needed
and so we returned
Heroes a band of retired Heroes also it
was Christmas and we had to catch up and
get our first couple videos going also
that happened yes we did yeah but it all
lined up we finished our all our work
and then suddenly
a moment a momentous occasion happened
yeah so we we started uh
the year off and
um we said hey man there's a lot going
on with um
with with all these AI art tools and and
we should do a video about it uh so we
we sought out to do you know a video
where
I'd take my law background and and talk
about
just the general legality of AI art
in total
um but then the question we were asking
was like do you own do you own the
copyright to the picture you generate
right that was the first and most
that was the first and foremost question
and then the second question was
followed by whether or not the
um
data set that goes into a lot of these
programs whether that data set is like
fair use or whether that that can be
protected or that that needs to be
licensed and all that stuff
but most of it was about whether or not
you could own the image that you
generate and then
a major class action lawsuit was filed
against civility Ai and uh so it shifted
the focus uh but it was great timing
because it allowed us to to hone in on a
very specific issue that's come up right
now
um and then well I was writing the video
on Tuesday
another lawsuit was filed in the UK also
against stability but this time it was
by Getty Images instead of the class of
defendants or the class of plaintiffs so
yeah very apt timing I think yeah I mean
and also
truly when it comes to like the legal
ramifications of all this stuff the one
that people truly care about and are
emotional about is is that latter issue
of
yeah are these models ethically trained
yeah are they are they ethically grown
models
so let's let's get into this stable
diffusion one because that's the one
that I have very good knowledge of after
doing five days of writing and so what
here's what they did they they went to a
German non-profit uh called lion and
they said hey guys uh we need you're a
research organization we we're gonna pay
you to come up with a data set of almost
6 billion images and so they went out
and they scraped the internet and
voila data
and then obviously you know how training
models work snico you're pretty familiar
with that so then they took that and
they made a huge model with it
yeah and then six billion images that
also had captions and yeah trained the
diffusion model how to generate images
along with where the captions pair with
those images so you can basically create
new things by calling into that point
later so here's my question here's my
question would would stable the fusion
be as good as it is if it didn't have
that data set if it wasn't trained on
that data set
they would have to have spent a lot of
time building a data set
well hold on yeah if Leon it's like
l-a-i-o-n right l-a-i-o-n is how it's
spelled yeah so they are the people
creating this data set so hold on why
wasn't the lawsuit filed against them
well because it's not it's not illegal
to scrape the internet for research
purposes
yeah
you can yeah and apparently in the in
Europe you can scrape you can scrape
data sets like that well so I read into
that and that's not necessary that was a
UK that was like a UK Council proposal
it's not a law they sold the data set
yes it was so that's the thing is that
they sold it and the thing is delay on
data set for free it's open sourced
right so the thing is is like
yeah it's very complicated quickly it
does get very complicated right now and
download it yeah I know I've seen I've
seen all those things so the tools to
like search it and stuff so the fact
that you can and I made this case too in
in the in the video but the fact that
you can download it for free does not
mean that it's not copyright
infringement right
so yeah I can download the Matrix for
free right exactly yeah through Torrance
that doesn't it's not like well Napster
was free so it's got to be okay right so
let's let's just secure set the record
here for everyone listening who's not in
so we're talking about AI again for the
millionth time and it's because it's a
conventionally evolving thing that is
always getting crazier and better and
more interesting yeah by the minute to
the point where now we're you know
heavily involved with all sorts of AI
stuff but um the point is is that what's
happening artists got angry
that their images made their way into
this data set that this model is trained
on yeah and it's recreating images that
resemble the work of an artist in
general yeah stylistically stylistically
kind of subject Mattery you can type in
if if you type in Thomas Kincaid
Farmhouse into stable diffusion trained
on Lion 5B it literally spits you back
out a painting-like image that looks
exactly like what Thomas Kinkade would
paint
but it's not it's not a replica of his
paintings right that's the one it's
distinction is it's not an actual copy
of yeah he's made right so we'll get
into that a little bit I just want to
click so so Sam yeah Sam sets the table
a little bit here and just you know
that's the gist of it there are these
huge data sets that get used to train
these AI generators they didn't ask
permission to include any of the work
that was included in the data set and
now the people who have work in the data
set have banded together to file a class
action lawsuit against the AI image
generator or against the company that
made it so the first question of whether
or not the data set is you can even do
that in the first place for research
purposes generally the answer is yes
they're also a non-profit organization I
don't know the distinctions and the
Nuance between like how you know Germany
Treats non-profits but I I think in
general that would be considered no
matter where you are like okay hey we
downloaded this it's for research now is
there some question as to whether or not
them just simply downloading all those
without permission and then making them
available to the public is copyright
infringement yeah but it's also the fact
that all of those images were already
available on the internet and there's no
inherent commercial use when you're
offering the data set to somebody else
so it's it's not exactly like the most
ripe like party to go after yeah it's
like that's like suing someone that's
like requesting damages because someone
downloaded a JPEG of your art and then
emailed it to their friend exactly which
is like that it's the same thing yeah
and so technically it's like well you
were only supposed to download it for
yourself you never should have shared it
with your friend but
you know I mean these this is a minor
issue so the the real issue is now you
know taking turning that data training
the stable diffusion model on it and
then offering that to the public and
then people go
look at the art that I made
and you know when so there's a lot of
issues here um so yeah you have this you
have this knowledge base this model
that's trained on the data and I guess
they're kind of saying like so this
model that you've trained because it's
trained on copy because it's trained on
lots of material and some of that
material is my material that you've used
therefore my copyright has now been is
now in your model and that is a
violation of my copyright
yes yeah so there's the first violation
that they're claiming which is just
simply you took my image and you'd use
it in a data set that now you're using
you know for your for your own companies
purposes and the value in part is based
on my work now they don't say that
through stable diffusion you can make a
copy direct copy of you know
who Sam name a name another artist in an
AI data set
just Greg gradkowski
okay we'll go to the classic example I
honestly didn't know about him until AI
stuff happened right and then I realized
oh wait a second I've seen all his work
and I just realized oh he's the guy who
makes all this cool DND fantasy yes yeah
so you know you've seen the painterly
images of dragons fighting man
that's you know Greg rokowski so
um yeah so anyways you can't make an
exact replica of his photo but what he
said what they're saying is hey look the
model trains itself on the image
and then the goal of the model if you
just trained it on one image would be to
replicate the image that you trained it
on
if you just train it on one image
now if you train it on six billion
images
then it's not going to look exactly like
any particular image that it has but
it's going to have what's called latent
data a latent data mesh
that's that's basically the accumulation
of all of the training that it's done on
all the images that you've given it and
so when you type in so it and it cannot
do that but for the copyrighted works
that you trained it on
so they're saying everything that it
creates is a derivative work because
everything that it creates is
necessarily built upon the things that
it's been trained on which I think is
honestly not a bad argument
um the question just simply really
becomes like whether or not
that use
transcends that whole idea because
there's this whole idea of called
transformative work
which courts really like it when a
company can say yeah I know that you
know you had all these book publishers
who had all these printed books and then
we scanned all of them without their
permission and made an index of them on
the Internet that people could then use
to read parts of the books but that's we
didn't do it to undercut the Publishers
we did it to offer it to a digitized
version of it to the public and then the
public can decide whether or not they
want to buy it from the publisher but
we're not selling the books that's what
Google did and so there's kind of a
similar thing going on here where
they're saying look if you want a Greg
Rakowski picture you know go and get one
from him like you know or you want you
want any you want a illustrated book or
you want whatever form of specific art
you might want you can go and get it
directly from that artist or wherever
they might sell stuff this is something
different this is a different use this
is this is used for you know
getting directly from an idea to an
immediate manifestation of idea it's not
necessarily used to hey look at I'm
replacing the market for Greg Rakowski
art because I used an AI image generator
generator to generate images that look
like his art
and I think that's an important
distinction because it doesn't
take away the value of his art as it
exists but at the same time
it might
it could it could it could it hasn't
quite happened yet like people's careers
haven't been destroyed by AI art
yet potentially right it's like really a
few months into this like careers
haven't been made they haven't been
destroyed like we're just yeah we're not
that's the craziest thing about it is
this only this program literally was
released publicly in August it's January
and and who so who knows
you know but like think about it this
let's take it take it take it and
extrapolate it one step further imagine
that you're Disney okay because they
love to sue everybody so imagine your
Disney and now
you have stable diffusion 3.0
and they just take every every movie
Under the Sun that they can that they
can grab they use it in their data set
and then they come up with an AI movie
generator I mean we are we are like
surprisingly quickly going to be at that
point yeah there is no reason why all of
a sudden just you you're not gonna be
able to hop to AI image generating from
or be able to hop from AI image
generating to movies or to be able to
hop into music or any other form of
consuming entertainment that you want
there you know that's gonna happen so
now imagine it this way okay I I'm
instead of
watching a movie instead of watching
what Disney's putting out or going to
the movies or renting a movie or
whatever it might be
I'm just gonna go on to stable diffusion
and I'm just gonna write a kids movie
about a magical genie in a bottle and an
Arabian princess and a young Dashing
Young man we have Aladdin at home kids
but that you know what I'm saying though
like that's it
okay I I got you I was trained on
Aladdin here's Aladdin yeah here's 11
but we made it look a little different
yeah we made it look a little bit
different and you know maybe it's
Summer's culture or some other place in
time with Aladdin it is that's the thing
yes that's exactly literally I have the
book right here A Thousand and One
Arabian Nights the last one
I mean that's this book yeah it's like
the the Thousand win one Arabian Nights
is where that that story originally came
from Alibaba and the 40 thieves that
whole thing the magic lamp like those
are those are folklore myths a lot of
them yeah but I mean you know we can't
discount you know there's a huge team of
like artists and people writing and all
that stuff too
transform
the elements of those folk tales yes and
make them digestible and entertaining
which totally is a serious feat and only
through the work that they've put in
they've been able to create a definition
of what an animated film should be in
the first place the question is do they
own the knowledge of what makes a good
animated film do they do they own the
knowledge of what makes a good Aladdin
animated film you know that's really the
questions you start to get into here
it's it's not just the expression itself
it's it's the it's the style behind it
and and how that translates through time
through different mediums of Art
because that's the real world of actual
copying like that hasn't changed like if
you use the AI to Output an exact image
of Genie from alad Disney's Aladdin you
couldn't say that that's your movie you
know that that's your genie because
that's that's a trademarked character
like that hasn't changed necessarily
right that hasn't changed at all does
the model if it can output Genie does
that constitute right copyright
violation but what if it's a green Genie
and it's called Gian and it comes out of
a mason jar instead
true yeah
so yeah because yeah I mean like I guess
what is the real difference here is it
just it's more intelligent knockoffs
you know yes but the other question is
whether or not and so so let's let's
just
hone in on this because it's not
necessarily the output that is an
infringement I I don't think I think if
it's it's whether or not the data is
fair use
is whether or not it's fair for another
person to take that without licensing it
or authorizing it from the original
owner
and then using it to create something
that is is trained on it well in a way
it's an entire ripple effect of legality
too where it's sure it's like is this
copyrightable is AI art copyrightable
it's like well hold on
like is how is the model sourced what is
what's the legal ramifications of just
that whole
aspect in the first place
I mean yes I feel like I feel like the
the best world to be in here like the
ideal policy that could come out is if
you train a model
on public data as in like people's
pictures or stuff they've written but
like you know you didn't get permission
for it it's just out there
if you train a model on it that model
also has to be public you know I feel
like that's the simplest like policy
like to implement like if you want to
have a model that's yours you're going
to sell and you're going to make it
exclusive
to do so with other people's copywritten
work and to build it off of that I feel
like starts to step over a line because
you've used content people have created
to generate value in that model
you know yeah well that's I guess that's
where we kind of get to this distinction
between models where let's say you have
like a mid-journey type model and let's
say there is this ruling that eventually
says well if it's if you know well I
mean mid-journ you have to pay for it so
there's that whole thing so but like
stable diffusion's raw so to speak yeah
you know if you are able to download
that and use the least stable of all the
diffusions yeah well then it starts to
become a thing where it's like okay well
if you're using this model you can't
copyright the work
because it's effectively just becoming
it it only outputs uh Creative Commons
so you know license fair use kind of
stuff it's probably worth delving into
that for a second here so we've been
talking you know the question is all
right so you pop open and a generator or
program specifically like stable
diffusion and you generate a picture do
you own that picture and as we've talked
about it we've come to the conclusion
that no you don't own the output so
that's the program yeah so that's a
separate issue from the whole issue of
whether or not that they're allowed to
use the data set to train a model but
let's talk about this one yeah that's
very specific question a lot of people
are confused about this and honestly I
think for a long time we were as well
but I I I I I spent the last week just
like in the copyright books
and there's no way there's no way
understanding how the models are built
and what the models are doing what
they're putting out if you go on to
stable diffusion and you type in
anything you you do not own that image
well you own it but you it is not
copyrightable
right it is not copyright you do not own
a copyright in that image and the
reasoning for that is that when you type
in prompts into a program like that
you're not creating an image you're
finding an image you're basically
activating different points in latent
space yeah it outputs an image in other
words it's a giant library and you've
typed in typed in an index very specific
that's a coordinate basically yeah
exactly based off of everything that
you're that your variables are it's not
even like impromptu it's all the
variables because we if we have the same
model on two different machines and we
enter the same prompt the same variables
all that stuff aka the same coordinates
yeah the same coordinates will both
generate the same image and that was
kind of the Breakthrough for these Pro
these programs was that they figure out
a way to give you a way to control
coordinates
through words they figured oh if we pair
the words in this way they basically act
as a vector right it's like a slider
almost it's a coordinate yeah it's a way
to access a coordinate oh I want to
access the the cat coordinate I want to
access the painterly coordinate I want
to access the black and white coordinate
you know these are all different points
on a graph and that's why a lot of AI
image generators are really deceptive
for most people out there because
they don't contain the full set of
variables to create that image like
mid-journey and Dolly are it seems like
oh it's just randomly constantly making
new stuff like but what what's happening
on the back end is they're probably just
changing like the seed they're changing
some of the variables in the background
so that way every single time you enter
a prompt you're always going to get a
new image and so it seems like this oh
it's a magic thing that constantly is
making different things but it's not
yeah it's almost like a fractal you know
yeah it's like
if I've rendered a fractal and you
rendered the fractal you don't have
copyright unless you did a special kind
of rendering like just that fractal it's
like owning a math equation right yeah
right this is just much more complex so
just just to explain exactly why that is
so the the the model is trained on
training images and it CR it creates
latent a latent understanding of all the
images that it's trained on yeah and
this this happens if you didn't watch
the video this happens through a process
of diffusion where they add they give an
image to a computer to a machine
learning program and they say
here's an image it's called an apple and
then they introduce more and more noise
over that image as slowly the image
becomes completely obscured and then
they go computer I just showed you what
an apple is make apple and the computer
goes okay I'm gonna here's a totally
obscured image I'm gonna we're gonna
remove noise from it here's what I think
an apple is maybe and and it just does
this a million times until eventually
it does it enough times where you're
correcting it you're correcting it
you're correcting it you're going no
that's not an apple more of this more
more Apple like this apple red apple
more Circle more apple green apple
Circle yes all of that and it it doesn't
know what an apple is it's just it just
knows what you're telling it to do and
then eventually it goes okay did I do a
good job and you go yes you did a good
job good job machine you've machine
learned your way back to understanding
what an apple is now next time I tell
you to show me an apple
show me that Apple that you made and it
goes okay got it boss that's what it
does and when you're doing when you're
typing in the word Apple all that you're
doing is you're triggering all the
relationships of visual forms that were
part of those apple pictures to be
paired with that word you could have
typed in banana and you'd have the same
exact results if you're using pictures
of apples right it's it's learning that
apples generally have this shape they
generally have this texture they
generally are pictured like this it's
just learning visual forms and shapes
and basically statistically relating
that to to any word that you give it in
this case you can get you give it Apple
yeah and that's Apple access your
coordinate so now in this case you have
fa in the specific case of stable
diffusion every program and model is
different but six billion images it's
done this on six billion images so when
you type in
you know
um a uh wrist watch a vintage wristwatch
made out of gold with uh you know
diamond
tickers I don't I'm really bad at
describing things um but yeah you know
like a golden wrist watch vintage golden
wrist watch it's gonna be like okay here
but it's all it's going to do is spit
you back a coordinate of latent data
that's so what it does it goes okay I
got wrist watches okay I've got ones
with like diamond crusted I've got ones
that are blue I've got ones that are
green I've got ones that are new I've
got ones that are old it takes all the
images that it possibly has in the in
the conditioning that you gave it and it
shoves it all together and then it
interpolates it into something that's
legible to the human eye and then it
matches like those visuals yeah it
matches it all and then it's like okay
this is this is this is going to look
like a vintage golden wristwatch and
then you go okay it created it from
scratch it's like no it didn't it didn't
create it because you told it to create
it it was just you were just like here's
a input coordinate and then it just ran
out found that thing and presented that
image to you so yeah in order to have a
copyright in something there has to be
what's called minimal creativity
and I don't think under almost any
analysis legally based upon what we know
about what is required for minimal
creativity which is not a lot
but it's enough where it has to
originate with the author
it has to originate with you you have to
be the progenator of it like the
literally the producer of the original
thing right and so typing it like oh all
my prompts are what made it creative
it's like no your prompts are just it's
taking your vector and you're just
adjusting where that Vector is in space
a little bit it doesn't matter how many
words you're giving it whether you're
saying Apple you're saying apple apple
or you're saying blue Apple Shiny Gold
all you're doing is like you could also
just find the abstract coordinate value
and you can type that in instead yes you
know yeah so so you have that and then
you also have this idea that that's a
process
it it's possible to patent I think it is
possible actually to patent a prompt
and it's not possible to copyright it I
don't think it's possible to copyright
it but it might be it might be possible
to patent it I don't know enough about
patent law but it's definitely not
possible to copyright it I mean
I don't want to say that with absolute
certainty because maybe somewhere
someday sometime some Court somebody
might say otherwise but
looking at it and looking at what's what
the history of like the decision on
minimal creativity has been
also it has to be an independent
creation of the author as well and the
whole coordinates thing using that
example if it's possible for somebody
else to find it
based upon what they know you already
did
then it's also not copyrightable if it's
possible for two people to find it
without knowing about each other then
technically it's still copyrightable but
I think minimal creativity is still the
the thing that it can't jump over yeah
if you if you type an apple with a seat
of one and I type in apple on a
different computer with a seat of one we
get the exact same image well do you do
you get the exact same exact same image
yep because like I said you're not
you're not generating an image you're
just going to the an index of where all
the different neurons meld to make that
specific image so I know that I know
that that's the case but and I just
thought it was like oh it's slightly
different you know it's not giving you
the exact coordinate because how could
it boil down all the coordinates into
that single user interface
and then no that's straight up you type
Appleseed one and I type in apple seed
one and we use the same model we end up
with the same image so it kind of boils
back to like it's the model that holds
the data is that true is that true Nico
because why is it when you type in apple
and then you click every time generate
it gives you a different image because
you had a random seed on so it was
changing the seed every time yeah you
can just walk the seat off but right now
by default it stays random so that's
that's also tricking people probably a
little bit too yeah because it's it's
it's a random scene that's what I was
saying earlier it's obviously you can
pick a seed between one and like you
know a million but still if we both pick
the same number we both get the same
image meaning that image wasn't created
when you when you when you typed your
prompt in it means the image is already
there you just accessed it right okay
yeah
it's like like you said it's like going
to a huge library and just because
you've went through all the indexes and
you found a particular paragraph in a
particular book and it was really hard
to find but you found it that doesn't
mean it's now yours yeah right there's
there's also no reward for it it's
called It's called The Sweat of the brow
Doctrine and it literally says there's
no reward in copyright for how hard you
worked
it's like well I worked really hard I
read all the books in the library don't
I get something and it's like not in
copyright you know maybe in life you get
something but but not in this law
uh no yeah yeah eventually eventually if
you take that output
and you do something more with it right
you do a collage or you start editing
the photos like if you take that output
and you just don't leave it as raw
output from the program but you start
adding your own process to it as an
artist it starts to enter copyright land
and you 100 100
as soon as you take it and you start to
do something with it that's not based
upon the way that you got the image in
the first place like you know if you if
you take it and then you start in
painting I still think
you know you start to enter copyright
land when you talk about impainting when
you talk about those those second and
third order uses
still it's it's if you made a collage
with it or you took it out and you
change even just changing like the color
of it from what it originally output and
doing some you know stylized
coloration to it making a collage with
it using it as you know an underlying
understanding of like a style book for
something that you're making
um any of that
obviously that stuff starts to
reintroduce the originality
I do want to talk about in painting
though because that's kind of the next
natural yeah find an image that you
really talk about in a painting yeah
that the pro the weird thing I still see
with that is the distinction of whether
you've done enough to alter it at all
because because of the amount of
variables and the prompt you're using
how would anyone I mean how would
someone find whether you have altered it
or not in the first place if they can't
find the original I mean obviously just
because you can't find the original
coordinates doesn't mean it doesn't have
coordinates yeah that doesn't mean that
it's that doesn't mean that it's
original though just because you can't
Maybe Can't duplicate it or find it
and you can just type it in and you get
the exact same picture
yeah but let's say you're some guy
making another comic here and you submit
it and they're like is hey did you tweak
any of this stuff and he's like yeah
well yeah then yeah I mean but you
didn't
well but even if it's like even taking
anyone to find out but if you take
pictures and you start putting them in
order and they are representing a story
that you've written you know not that
also yeah so so again that now starts to
introduce copyright you could take an
entire thing
that's that all the images are taken
just by prompting simple prompts in an
AI program
but if you start to take those you start
to arrange them in a certain way such
that now all of a sudden the arrangement
itself starts to have
originality
that is copyrightable because you did
that yeah but it's like the arrangement
could be copywritten but the images
themselves yes are it's the same thing
with facts I mean you could write a book
about World War II it could be the most
striking greatest work ever of history
but it you can't it doesn't mean you
can't tell somebody else that they
cannot write about World War II like
those are facts yeah you know and so you
cannot analogy you can't take those with
you but you can take the arrangement of
them with you and you can't say the this
Arrangement is mine yeah
so that took us to the really you know
once we kind of figure out this like
output thing that really boiled it down
to the model and you had to really start
digging into the legalities around the
model now yes right because well and you
taught me this but I thought that you
know like every version of stable
diffusion had was you know had the same
model or whatever
um yeah but oh you can make you can make
lots of models yeah you can make endless
models I love it and and you can take
your own data and then have it train on
that data like which is what you did
yeah which is what you've done when you
did the whole you know you took
everyone's face and then you were able
to make a story with everybody and you
had me and Sam and Christian and Steve
the landlord and and everybody and that
is now original because that is from
work that you took outside brought it
into the program and then you ran the
same training on those images but the
images you brought in were original to
you
that now reintroduces originality back
into the outputs yeah
so it really seems like the the lawsuit
here specifically has to call out
almost like specific models like hey
when disability released 1.5 that model
is specifically infringement of our
copyright
so yeah yes yes they do and they do call
out the the main one that they call out
is is Lyon 5B which is the data set the
data set yeah and the models any any
model that's built on that data set is
that you know you're not changing or
whatever that's that's what they're
saying and just just quickly to clarify
for listeners a data set is basically
like the images or like you know video
files sound files basically the actual
data you would train a model on and then
the model
is effectively the knowledge that you've
now trained for your AI the machine
learning algorithm it's so to speak it's
like it's like the neural network once
it's processed things it processed
things and like kind of learned how to
represent things you know that's that
knowledge would be referred to as your
model it's like when we make a deep fake
we have data sets which is just you know
thousands of pictures of people's faces
and then you train the model it tries to
replicate those faces and that data file
that it makes it kind of has that
ability to replicate faces that would be
the model
so it's like the knowledge in here after
you read a book but it's not the book
the book is still the book
yeah
so yeah that's
um that's part of what they bring up is
you know they they started they pinpoint
a specific data set and they say okay
because of this data set that's how the
infringement is happening
but again this isn't about the
infringement I don't think it's it's
like pretty obvious to me that it's
infringing it's just about whether or
not whether or not they're allowed to
get away with it because they're
introducing a new use why is it
obviously that's an it's infringing why
do you say that well I I think there's
two things I mean first when you just
straight up take the image without the
authorization from the copyright owner
and then you use that in a in a data set
that
isn't just for research that's going to
be used in a model that you're gonna
exploit later on I mean that's that's
unauthorized reproduction you could make
a very basic argument to say that that's
a infringement of the right of
reproduction
um which is one of the exclusive rights
of copyright holders but I think the
better argument that they make is the
derivative work argument
um and to say that because all of the
images that the model generates are
directly derived
from all of the training images that you
gave it
it's not like it's it's not like yeah I
know that I used your song you know but
Paul McCartney but I also I changed a
couple of the words it's like no it
didn't it's just it just Blended 800
000 different songs together that you
that are equally still owned by somebody
else there there's nothing original that
it's adding when it gives you one of
those outputs and so that's a good
argument that's a good argument that
it's a derivative work but then if you
argue that it's a derivative work then
the the next question which so
derivative work just to be clear that's
one another exclusive ride of copyright
holders you have the right of
reproduction you have the right of
derivative work it's called the
adaptation work it's like hey you want
to make a movie out my book or you want
to make a second edition of my book or
whatever it might be you got to ask me
you can't just go out and make it and so
that's what they're saying the program
cover of a song or a cover of a song
yeah well there's a special exception
for covers of songs but I won't get into
that there is
um but anyway yeah so so that's what
they're saying
um but as soon as you make that argument
then the next argument that the
defendant makes is well it's not a
derivative work it's transformative
because I took I took it and it's fair
use man everyone does the whole don't
shoot me okay it's fair use it's it's
safe you know I know you you might not
like it and look we do this too to a
certain degree we make derivative works
all the time yeah we're gonna make our
video game films back in the day yes and
those are those are Spiderman
yeah those are pretty clearly derivative
works but sometimes you know sometimes
they're transformative and we are and we
argue that all the time like how is it
that we're able to make yeah Spider-Man
rated R and monetize that well the first
reason is that you know because how
prolific that property is in the public
mind which also leads to a better
argument for fair use if you have a work
like Star Wars and it's like yeah we
made a Darth Vader thing it's like yeah
technically that's that's a derivative
work based upon a copywritten character
that's copyright infringement
you know it's yeah but it's clearly
supposed to be funny and it's parody
it's not yeah another entrance into the
Star Wars saga being so so that's the
thing is when you start to get into it's
like yeah I know that this is so take
Darth Santa okay that's a good example
we didn't then go out and say okay we're
gonna take Darth Vader okay and then
we're gonna tell New Canon in the world
of Star Wars and this is what else this
is what happened to him guys okay now
now look at it this way and
so closely right it's not so closely
tied to where the character comes from
that somebody would be like wait is this
is this from George Lucas
you know like everybody knows that and
that that honestly lends itself into a
better argument for fair use and but
then in addition to it being
widely disseminated in the public mind
also we took it and we we took the
character that is the copywritten
character and we made a we made a new
use of him he's no longer this stalking
brooding you know silent Darth Master of
the Universe he's this funny guy who's
friends with his Stormtroopers and he's
out there having fun and causing
Mischief you know and he's got a son and
like he's got a Santa hat he's got a
Santa hat on and he's putting scorpions
and and stockings and he's just being a
rap scallion and it's like that that
obviously is a huge departure from where
the character comes from and it's a
totally different use of that character
so I think there's a good argument that
that's transformative fair use
especially because it doesn't undermine
the value for the original it's not like
oh yeah you know what I saw Dar Santa so
actually I'm good on all the other Star
Wars problems
you know that but if you did that if it
had that effect then that would matter
as well
and so the court the courts take into
consideration all of those things like
it's not and it's not any one particular
thing it's it's like a totality of the
circumstances
so where where do you stand on this Jake
give me give me your actual your judge
now I've made you judge Andrew oh man
executioner if you so desire so this is
one of those things where like now I
understand the terrifying weight that
would be on your mind with certain
things when you are when for people that
are Judges like somebody this has to go
before a judge and it's not going to go
before a jury because that's not a
copyright law works so a judge will have
to sit there and look at it and consider
all the precedent
I would want to consider more precedent
that would be the first thing
well you'd want to consider what uh so
the way that the U.S court system works
is you have the Supreme Court obviously
which is you know the ultimate decider
of of legal questions in the land but
then below that at a federal level
you have what are called the Appellate
districts and there's a bunch of these
all over the country but there's nine
districts in particular
um and and those districts are bound by
other decisions that have happened in
their District but not necessarily Bound
by things that haven't happened in their
District so this is a common thing that
happens in music copyright all the time
there's the second circuit or is there's
the second district which is covers
Nashville and there's the Ninth District
which covers Los Angeles and they're
always fighting because the SEC yeah the
second district is bound by the rules
that other courts in the second district
have made and the ninth circuit is bound
by other rules that other courts in the
Ninth District have made
but they're not necessarily in agreement
all the time huh so so then sometimes
those things go up to the Supreme Court
and then the Supreme Court has to say
okay here's what we're going to follow
and but usually by the time it gets to
the Supreme Court it's already
like there's already been you know a ton
of a ton of things that have been
decided and really usually all the
courts are asking the Supreme Court to
do is go is it this way or is it this
way
because we already you know we already
decided all the rest all the nuance and
so
I would want to consider more precedent
because that would matter and it would
also to matter what district you're in
if you were a judge deciding this that
the one that we're talking about uh
uh uh in the video is a ninth circuit
court so you'd want to you'd want to go
over that go over that thoroughly but at
the end of the day
I think in the ninth circuit they're
gonna decide that it's fair use because
there's such a tech heavy
presence of of like you know trying to
encourage the public benefit that
results from Tech the development of
Technology
um now it's also a very Arts heavy
District which is why it's being filed
there
um
but
that's just where my gut leads me you
had to decide based on your research oh
if I had to decide
good God that's
um I mean I guess I'll decide it's just
a it's just a an exercise right it's
just an exercise
if I was if I was the judge and this was
coming to me right now
I would decide that it's copyright
infringement because it's too early I
think
to to decide you know the fate of
because once you decide that it's fair
use it's like okay now you know the
implications are are everywhere it's
like well now let's make movie
generators let's make music generators
let's make it more image generators
let's make all the generators let's just
do do it all and we can take it all from
the internet and there's no consequences
and then it becomes a it becomes an arms
race to the first person that can do
that and the most effective means and
then basically charge a subscription for
it that's yeah basically it means
somebody benefits from all the public
data and then the public doesn't benefit
from their benefit right and so I I
don't I it might be such a
transformative use that you know that's
okay but I think given that this just
came out like we're talking about August
a lot of times you know this stuff has
been going on for years before
you know these cases come up but now
this is like boom right away
so I do think it's good that they're
getting out ahead of it but given how
new it is and how little we understand
the implications if I was the judge I
would decide it's copyright infringement
because you can always bring a later use
that's similar back before the court and
make another decision you can't bring
the same case obviously because it's
race judicata but you can bring similar
things similar tools are going to result
similar examples that are going to have
the same ultimate effect are gonna
happen and so right now I would go no
way this is way too hot to like make
this you know very
impactful decision
when there's no other technologies that
have existed like it
let's let's hold the phone on this right
now it's infringement
bring it back up in another District
later see what they say let it start to
Bubble up here and there see what the
consequences are here and there and
that's what the great thing about the
the Federated system of America though
is you can have these little Petri
dishes that's the that's the strength of
it you can have these things that bubble
up here bubble up there you know see how
they work and how the weights and
balances of how it affects the public
versus how it affects the artists versus
how it affects the AI in the tech
companies and the development of
further future Technologies and you can
weigh all that over time in multiple
different areas and then ultimately as
those things gain enough speed as they
gain enough steam then you know make a
greater decision on it yeah that's
really interesting and it's also worth
noting that like if it was ruled that
like this model was infringement
specifically this data set in this model
like model being 1.5 for example
like that doesn't mean it's the end of
the program the program's not a
copyright infringement it's a model yes
and Dolly you know and open AI like
dolly was trained on cleared uh images
they cleared my rights for their images
right so they are in this lawsuit
because they they effectively got all
the rights to actually use those images
yeah they're in a they're in a patent
lawsuit but but still yeah yeah
um but that's interesting because that
does kind of like not necessarily a
sense of precedent but it does show that
there is a way to do it that doesn't
involve just scraping all the images
without permission and then the other
thing is it's not hard to make your own
models so it's not the death of like
cool art models like right imagine you
know imagine you train a base model on
the you know copyright cleared images
and you can do all the things that can
replicate generally it can replicate
people it's got all the you know the
copyright free art and painting from you
know up to like 100 years ago or
whatever like it's got a bunch of like
copyright clear pictures so it clearly
can represent forms it's got a bunch of
different subjects and then if you want
to like really train in a specific art
style you can always just do that on
your own it takes like a few days at
most you know if you really want to like
replicate an artist or a Vibe or you
want to mash together some things to get
really cool aesthetic like yeah but I
can't do it with my phone right now Nico
I need it instantly now yeah right now
yeah yeah so that's a good point too and
I I don't think that because it's it's
hard to understand the distinction
between the program and a model of the
program that's not innately that's not
self-evident that it's just two
different things
um and that they can be different
there's a ton of value in the program
itself a ton of value like a
incomprehensible amount of value
um and it's crazy that it can do what it
does it's just man can you do it with
just
I can't just I don't know something
seems wrong about that something seems
wrong about that right now like just let
me just give you all the data that you
can get I don't care where it comes from
well the reality I don't really care who
made it people are going to argue like
well the the model doesn't actually
store images they'd be like you you try
to find the Mona Lisa you can't actually
get the Mona Lisa out of it no you can
get a you can get a nightmare fuel
version of the Mona Lisa out of it but
at the same time it's like true but also
if you over train a model on an image or
a small set of images you can get it to
replicate that image you know so it's
like yeah you just have the compression
slider turned down a certain ways like
but at what point does it become lossy
enough does it become different enough
we're like okay it's no longer
replicating that image
but you know the other argument to be
made regardless like because the model
isn't storing your images right it's the
the data set of images of the six
billion images is 50 terabytes which
once again you can just you can go and
start downloading it right now it's free
to download it's 50 terabytes yeah but
the model itself is like four gigabytes
right so it's 50 terabytes of the
pictures compressed down to a four
gigabyte neural network so it's not
storing the pictures per se
but at the same time
the value of that model
comes from the data it was trained on
and if there if you're getting value
from that model because it was trained
on copywritten work
you know it starts to be like well yeah
I mean it just it's to sum it up the
model is derivative of the artist's work
yeah yeah
and the other day I think that's it is
you know
but we'll remember when the stable
diffusion came out I mean the first
thing we all said about it was look at
how good this thing is but you also
can't copyright a style and where does
the difference between the artist's work
and his style just like if because we do
a Greg Rakowski style painting but it's
not one of his paintings right that's
just it it's not one of his paintings
it has the style of his painting but
it's like he didn't create it you know
it was just trained on all of his
paintings he's just trained us and it's
true and it's literally trying to give
you one of his paintings it just doesn't
know which one to give you yeah it was
created in order to recreate his
painting yeah yeah no that's the wacky
thing about it
is it's like if it could it would it's
just doesn't can't quite give you the
exact one
but I've also heard the argument that
you know well
who was it I just lost it uh
turn in his paintings
that are a spirit okay
copywriting a style though that's yeah
that's a that's an important Point
um
you
cannot copyright a style you
might no you can't even trademark it
yeah because it's not precise enough
um you can trademark patterns and things
like that
uh you know like a Louis Vuitton bag or
whatever
um but you can't yeah you can't do that
with a style
I still think the solution to all this
is just to be like hey if you want to
use publicly scraped data for your model
the model and the data set have to be
publicly available it's like that go for
it you know but it you can't own it yeah
that's that's pretty good and I you know
that's a good like Band-Aid I think for
now yeah I guess I just I think about
like Google or Microsoft like it says
chat chat GPT you know it's basically
GPS elevated a little bit so people are
starting to use that to replace Google
and it's way better than Google like
Google sucks these days Google search
really sucks like the internet's kind of
been broken to like take advantage of it
so you can't actually search for
anything kind of
kind of they do 60 of the ad data that
gets spent on the internet goes through
Google yeah so it's like you don't
actually get results for stuff you get
advertisements regardless of whether or
not it's a sponsored thing so in in the
search for people just trying to learn
things like hey I like I have an error
code what does it mean it's like my
buddy Jan you know like our buddy Jan
like he'll type that into chat gbt3 but
hey what does this error code mean and
it tells him it'll be like how do I fix
it and then it tells him and if it's
still too complicated he might type
explain it to me like I'm a child and
then it tells them like in simpler terms
and so it's like a really smart version
of Google and he's doing the code thing
too where he'd be like I don't know how
to install this like python thing and
then yeah we'll tell them yeah it'll be
in type in this code okay so it's like
that's fascinating it's fascinating it's
also terrifying because you're gonna get
back it's not gonna like proof check it
it's just gonna be like I don't know
it's like
no it doesn't yeah this is going to eat
Google's lunch oh man at least the
search results and Microsoft's probably
trying to jump onto it you know a bunch
of people are trying to jump onto it
right now so it's like yeah that's
something where it's like oh a cool big
old tech company is gonna go out there
and scrape all the whole internet and
everything that everybody's written and
they're going to turn it to their own
model to then make themselves a billion
dollars you know because they don't have
the search results it's the same thing
though you know it's funny it's like oh
gpd3 it's like how did you make it it's
like all those poor journalists writing
those articles all that work was derived
it was to create those models where are
their voices where's their class action
lawsuit right yeah no you're right
honestly it's the exact same thing and
like yeah I just it feels weird for a
company to train on data that
everybody's worked together to create in
a public way trying to keep it for
themselves yeah basically it just means
that when the singularity happens
uh everyone is gonna Sue it
Google's been walking that line sense
their existence you know and they've
done a they've done a decent job
placating the different interests that
have attacked them
uh to to be where they are today but you
know that was
that was a big issue at the dawn of the
internet
um and that was that was the issue it's
it's just the same issue it's just re
replicating itself in a more complicated
manner I think now but the issue being
can Google just serve you all that stuff
without asking anybody and that's true
it's like Google's yeah Google's kind of
got in trouble like remember the picture
stuff like you do an image search on
Google and Google just serve you the
image and people like hey that image was
on my website you're not allowed to do
that you can send it to my website if
they want the image yeah you know and
now like Google tries to do the thing
where they cut down like facts where
it's like hey Google how round is the
Earth you know like how how far would I
have to walk to walk around the earth
and like it'll give you like a fact
snippet from a web page you know at like
the top results now what won't do is
just give you the text without citing a
source because that would be copyright
infringement right just clip it and give
it to you
but if an AI rewrites it a little bit
you know but that's effectively what
chat gbt is because there's no there's
no copyright in facts there's only a
copyright in the
presentation and arrangement of a fact
yeah so yeah that's kind of what's
happening again
in in a lot of ways it's just obviously
on the chat gpt3 side or the chat gpt3
but yeah on that side it's
happening
more in a
in a broad context of like human
knowledge yeah it's not like oh I stole
the style of Stephen King yes and
everything is written in the voice of
Stephen King but you guys sometimes you
could ask it to do that if you wanted it
to narrate it yeah how do I solve this
code problem narrate it to me like a
Stephen King novel
you know it's just mentioning like with
this stuff like you talk about precedent
but it never hurts to also make some new
rules when the time comes up oh totally
you know and there there will have to be
because I think this presents novel uh
issues that haven't existed before just
like the question of the first questions
of Google when it was when the first
questions were Can it can it scrape all
this data across the internet and
present it to you and then put an ad on
it and index it can it's an index it
yeah and you know ultimately we decided
collectively as as a people we said you
know what this is a this is a public
service in a way and there's value to it
and so we we allowed that we allowed
allowed that to go on now it appears
that that there's a another
few iterations that are happening in
a few different areas through the use of
AI and machine learning
yeah
fascinating stuff
yeah I'm excited for this year because
this stuff's going to continue to happen
quick and
um you know we're just trying to
play with it learn it have fun with it
understand it see what we can do with it
and I just hope that the people involved
maintain it in an open way like they've
been you know people have been doing so
far but not everybody you know if you're
a researcher out there doing this stuff
and you're keeping it closed
think about that you know just think
about that a little bit
right are you are you helping Humanity
that much when you don't tell anybody
else you might be helping your research
uh Finance here but
yeah and you know granted there's a
balance people are putting in time but
if you're benefiting from the knowledge
of others
right you know
kind of a dick move if you just keep it
up yeah I mean that's that's a fair
point like we all benefit from the
knowledge of others and the others who
came before us yeah like can you imagine
how arduous and absurd life would be if
humans weren't able to transfer
knowledge to each other yeah I mean we'd
be we would be no we would be animals
just straight up animals
yeah it would be awful and disability
ai's credit like these models are
dropped for free and the data set it's
open source you can grab it and the code
it's open source so they've they kind of
you know they they put their money where
their mouth was a little bit and even
though there's not rules that say they
have to do that they're doing it and so
they're kind of just leading by example
much in a way that you know open AI led
by example of clearing the rights for
their data set but they're also really
behind closed doors and you can just see
how like dolly is really cool but also
look how stagnant it is and how in a way
they've created something amazing that
they then aren't letting people use
whereas stable diffusion is unlocking
all these wonderful doors for so many
people and it's the people themselves
doing it you know it's not a giant
Corporation right just doing it behind
closed doors you know yeah and that's
that's fair point and you know that's
how else do you get conversion and and
proliferation of users and all that
stuff and to really figure out because
you got to figure out we don't even know
what the value of this stuff is yet
what is the value of stable diffusion
it's it's like well we know it's worth
something we know that it's we know that
it's really interesting and it's
fascinating and it's like this super
computer in terms of
what it can deliver to you but no one's
quite exactly put their finger on
what's exactly valuable about it yet and
so at this point it is very valuable to
the public to have it open but see that
leads into the argument that it needs to
be fair use you know it's yeah it's
and I don't think that's a wrong
argument either like if the court
decided that I wouldn't be like how
could oh my God
you know I would just I would be like
yeah that makes sense I see why they
would decide that
yeah so
we'll see what happens hopefully the
Nuance exists and people don't just turn
it into like hate fests and team sports
yeah but Nico that takes all the fun out
of it you know that's like the only way
people say people get a real thrill
these days
[Applause]
with this abundance of food and
technology and availability of anything
at your fingertips I mean where is the
real controversy
yeah that's right I need a cause yeah I
need to Hitch my wig in on one of these
trains hell yeah Brothers they're all
leaving the station
[Laughter]
brutal yep
all right Sam do you have any last words
on this
no you guys summed it up
I'm glad you could be here Sam no that's
it Sam's gonna keep using it that's what
he's gonna do yeah I'm gonna keep using
it hell yeah don't hate me
don't hate to play I hate the game yeah
it's like bro I'm like so many levels
down from like the actual like cause of
this stuff you know right right I'm
innocent I mean hey we have a we have a
cool project that we're doing that
explicitly uses custom trained models in
a custom process very excited about it
do something very special we haven't
shown any of it yet
and when we do show it and we make this
thing or we're already making it but
like when we put it out there we're
going to tell everybody exactly how I
did it yeah everybody can do the same
thing and maybe lie a little bit to just
throw them a wrench
there'll be one complete lie about the
process so uh yeah anyways uh so that
looks like this
yeah but you know it's like it's the
openness of the software that allows us
to do what we're doing on our project so
yeah like I said it'd be a dick move if
we just kept it close but also if we
share our technique
ideally people also jump in and research
it and experiment it and refine our
technique and we end up whistling really
cool because the whole idea is that it
the thing we're doing allows us to do a
really creative thing a lot faster than
we used to right yeah being very vague
here we'll talk more about it soon yeah
no that's going to be great uh that'll
be out in a few more weeks on corridor
and we'll do a whole video on how we did
it and how you can do it on Corridor
crew yeah
so stay tuned for that
2023 is a good year it's gonna be a good
yes sir all right
I'm gonna play us out Sam do you still
want me to continue in D Minor or do I
dare I know it's much more uplifting now
okay we've solved our problems we can
see the sunlight
like this
yeah just like that oh
maybe like an A Minor you know a little
bit of mood
of course
we've solved it for everyone
no more reasons to lead bad no more
reasons to leave comments on Reddit that
you don't like
when someone's computer makes a bad
image yeah yeah you gotta say they are a
bad person
see you later